[Music]
welcome back to this special edition of
Hannity Trump versus the resistance with
the fourth of July right around the
corner few hours from now one of the
biggest social justice warriors in the
country is showing his patriotism by
calling the American flag racist that's
right ex NFL quarterback Colin
Kaepernick reportedly told Nike that
it's shoe featuring the iconic Betsy
Ross flag was offensive because 250
years ago some Americans own slaves
Nike subsequently pulled the shoe from
its store shelves keep in mind this is
the same Betsy Ross flag prominently
displayed at President Obama's second
inaugural there was no outrage back then
I didn't hear from Colin Kaepernick but
naturally many in the mainstream media
or backing Nikes decision calf attacks
faux moral out--we rage notwithstanding
take a look this Republican in this faux
outrage is just it's almost laughable I
mean look the shoe the flag it
represented a period of time where with
all due respect I was three-fifths of a
human being and so that is an issue
people don't want to go back to that
time when you look at that early version
of the American flag what does it
symbolize well I see it I see the 13 I
see the colonies and that leads directly
to slavery in some cases the Betsy Ross
flag has been co-opted by white
supremacist groups like the KKK
now this flag has been used by people
who want to pummel African Americans
Latinas Jews and other people neo-nazis
who want to claim that they have their
true copyright on American identity so
why not choose a flag that is
representative of everybody of course
it's not just the media several twenty
twenty Democratic candidates also
weighing in and trashing the great
American flag joining me now to talk
about a Salem radio nationally
syndicated host Larry elder Catalina
magazine publisher Kathy aru good to see
you both so Larry
um I guess colin kaepernick runs nike
these days and so you know what's next
red white and blue sneakers will be
banned uh no white sneakers will be
banned because you know that's white
supremacy
who knew that colin kaepernick had this
kind of power
my goodness he was able to get Nike to
recall his shoe that they'd already
manufactured all because he complained
what would have happened had the Colin
Kapernick not complain Greg and the shoe
would come out nobody would have cared
so this was all Colin Kaepernick's call
it is absolutely stunning he doesn't
have a problem with the flag as you
pointed out Obama had not one but two
big bestir ox legs and his second
inaugural and the current flag that
we've had since 1960 has 13 stripes on
it one of which for every one of the
original 13 colonies and it's got 50
stars 13 of which are again representing
the original 13 colonies so Colin
Kaepernick has a problem not with the
Betsy Ross flag but with flags in
general and don't go to a Philadelphia
76er game because that same Betsy Ross
Ignat insignia is their is their logo
right you know Kaffee ain't come on
since I'm confused it never occurred to
me that that the you know I thought 13
colonies was represented by the Betsy
Ross flag since when is it really
meaningful as white supremacy symbols
since Colin Kaepernick brought it up and
it's caused so many people conversation
he is the final arbiter with moral
supremacy not the fine no not the final
19 he is starting the conversation no
Nikes made billions of dollars with this
partnership with Kaepernick he is a
social justice warrior he is starting or
part of a counterculture movement in
this country that is so American and so
patriotic to question everything and
don't just believe everything let me ask
you this why is it Colin Kaepernick why
is it Colin Kaepernick concerned about
Nike moving a lot of their production
jobs to China which is one of the
world's biggest abuser of human rights
including imprisonment and torture and
execution of people who dare to disagree
with their government but I'm not
hearing Colin get upset about that one
one issue at a time and Arizona is
taking out its factory and California is
saying bring it over to us so we should
be very upset
with Arizona and they're moving Germany
not to light that Arizona is taking away
500 jobs well California said bring them
to us so California is actually
complaining about China taking the jobs
so good for Kapernick to make a point
that California wants to bring those
jobs back to America so the conversation
is there I'll leave it to you to to
correct Kathy on this issue well Kathy
said one issue at a time of all the
issues facing this country and facing
black America in particular the Betsy
Ross she who doesn't even make the cut
if Colin Kaepernick has this kind of
power this kind of persuasiveness and
this kind of cloud on social media
how about dealing with the number one
problem facing black America and that's
the lack of fathers in the home how
about dealing with the poor government
schools that kids go to how about the
dropout rate in some inner-city kids and
some inner-city schools approaching
almost 50% and those who graduate often
cannot read write interviewed at grade
level
how about dealing with some of these
trivial problems now that we've met I
think you'd be very upset because Betsy
Ross was a remarkable woman who had her
own business and she you know showed the
flag and created the flag I think you'd
be sticking up for yes and I am so happy
that Kaepernick brought up the issue
that Betsy Ross made this flag and she
couldn't even vote at the time that she
actually made the flag nice and now
we're talking about it nicer face thank
you very much Larry alder Kathie they
have very much there's more